wieder einmal war und mit seinen
freunden drei kopfball an heute mit
diesen wunderschönen medien und heute
machen wir drei giftige cocktail die
bba'ler stanglpass auch noch zum thema
stimmt und was ist die wichtigste zutat
sie uns natürlich ein stürmer
[Applaus]
ja ich muss mir auch die giftigste zum
glück waren gehen wir einkaufen jetzt
privaten einkommen von magic zutat des
mülls in deiner welt machen wir milch
aus dem magic zu treffen
calida kurzer sinn es ist halloween
oktober monaten alle hier komplett aus
mal jähre an sanktionieren vorstellen
ich hab den stand und man mit krokant
eis und milch natürlich und wir alle
machen die körper in 40 rhein-main
kocher pop up shops und über 18
[Musik]
ich habe weil es ist ja ein hallo gefühl
ich habe ein paar sachen weil es wird ja
auch finanziert und ich glaube da liegt
momentan meine stärke drin denn ich
denke mal werden kein problem wenn ich
auch gefahren ich hatte vor kurzem
scheiße okay weil das wäre natürlich
gewesen für alle von uns und sagen
deswegen habe ich jede menge holz aber
ich sehe diese fakten über
nacktschnecken optimal was sie gewusst
dass nach drängen wie vögel legen die
eier und schauen dass da aber nicht so
weit oben
nur 2 es gibt viele arten von dachsen
zum beispiel die zieger schnecke und
halt neue nummer drei das gucken wir mal
wieder ein sachen gekauft und guck mal
nicht so läuft
gekauft ich für meine dienste nutzer
links kommt die hauptzutat muss milch
sein und ich muss sagen diese milch
gefällt mir ganz besonders die schmeckt
nach seinen träumen
braunau
oder sagen es nicht gebacken und kennst
mich was ich kann nicht eine nicht
verstehen nicht röschen produkte genau
wie ich drauf stetig gewachsen da kommt
ihm ein cocktail jährige die zuschauer
schon vorher das nicht verpackt zum
glück können wie mit worten acht euro
neuen boutique grütze gewollt weil es
ich das wort ganze ist so geil es ist
schon allein so halloween haare dem
haben
ich wollte kurz in der hose solange die
das spiel
und jetzt gehen wir unter gegen so ein
fahrstuhl
[Musik]
wir sollten einfach so okay das ist
jetzt mal geil ich glaube ich die ganze
zeit das gut kommt der moment nicht raus
stellt ob es gut funktioniert oder nicht
so und du bist sagt dass er entdeckt
jobs macht du hast gesagt dass sich der
juke wann hast du das gesagt war ihm
halt in der stadt und das stimmt auch
nicht wirklich knapp eine strategie der
junge mann geschaut die drei eigentlich
halten du warst du gerade irgendwie so
kunst
für mich wirkt sich eine komplette lacht
wo warst du [ __ ] ja seit vier wochen
verlängern will
mir geht es im moment total beschissen
für mich missverstanden erniedrigt und
als frau total unterdrückt und geknetet
ist nicht mein ding kann damit umgehen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
eine stelle mal denn mir geht es im
moment total beschissen für mich
missverstanden an gericht und
[Musik]
ich bin auf diät ich bin auf die geht
oft mit meinem fahrzeug jetzt was los es
steht ihm nicht nur ich bin sogar den
hängen geblieben wo ich sagen wir so
sicher bin dass wir nach 20 minuten
anfangen würden wir auszuschenken
verzweifeln weil wir so lange brauchen
für alles änderte die sich superspion
der distanz ab dem fingernagel und jaja
superspion ich kenne hier aufpassen die
wird irgendwas wieder an den deutschen
grenzen schlug leben auch wenn alkohol
[Musik]
berlin oder wie sieht auch diese schaden
würden sind
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der schritt wo ich zwar kaffee aber wo
geht die reise los
ok
zur gleichen zeit findet dass es noch
okay also nicht einfach lernen wir also
meine erklärung der geschmack mich dir
bei carry letzten wochen wichtige schon
die maschine angekommen und dann sollten
gespenst wein mit ein bisschen also erst
geschmäcker sind da drin honig und
zucker zitrone und sogar elf ich nicht
ich bin auf diät
[Musik]
ja das kann man wohl sagen ich muss
sagen die geschmäcker schmeckt man alle
einzeln voraus weil sie nicht wie sonst
eine symbiose ergeben
also muss seine stilistisch wie du auch
hier wieder gleich sehen wirst hätte ich
so was von mir erwartet auch noch nicht
also es ist halt schon schon so
[Musik]
ich dachte da kommen lassen
ist aber anscheinend falsch denn die das
interessiert mich wirklich wie ich das
trinken sondern strohhalme also dass man
eine mit beruflichen pickel darstellen
der albtraum jedes team majors und
wieder so ein bisschen blut dann braucht
so weiß und wieder klassik von unten
nach oben ziehen
niemand muss man hier mit diesem ja ich
hab dann hast du den sich sicher mit dem
alkohol und im milchschaum machen nicht
präsentieren
also ich habe mich nicht ich habe mir
nach produkte täuscht sich ich dachte
mir erst mal den ranken darf man ist ja
schon seit 1
bei dem glas dann muss leider sagen ich
dachte die wahren fakten akt schmücken
will keine tiere gemeinschaften und
zusammenschlüsse der bekanntestes
bekannt und nahm nur drei nacktschnecken
sind im durchschnitt zwischen 27 cm und
also zwischen diesem weg und haben kann
jeder noch ein bisschen kicken macht ein
bisschen ein bisschen spaß party
unterlassen die ihre tour an sich
relativ sind wir in der westlichen welt
gilt das netz als beleidigung wegen
ihrer langsamkeit
das ist es brauch in krakau oder was es
ist aber die schnellste der welt ist
hier schon kraftakt für die nackte kommt
ursprünglich aus kolumbien auch wieder
ganz lang beschäftigt
der charity hast du wieder abgerückt und
gehörte mit dem sonderpreis zu übergeben
für die kreativsten ideen ich habe halt
braucht direkt in peking gab es folgende
geschichte der koch hält also einer dame
erhoben
abonnieren sie hier austria
multiplizieren
wo ist eigentlich noch weiter die summe
jetzt biste was wir suchen jetzt kommen
die beine getroffen musst du einen
klettern können ich hasse euch